Okay.
I said No.
Richard also asked,
how can I talk about the resentments of
my childhood in a way that benefits them
instead of giving them guilt?
I don't know if I can
answer that question,
Richard,
because it's,
it's not a question that's,
see what I would ask if you came to
talk to me and you have that question.
I would say first of all,
well
what resentments?
List them out,
man.
Write him down.
Okay,
so the,
you know what they are.
Because all of those,
each of those resentments is going to
be a different thing and the strategy
that's associated with each might vary
as a consequence of the particularity of
the resentment.
So I would say you should start by
writing them down like what's your problem
exactly here.
Here's all the things that I can think
of that I'm angry about with regard to my
childhood.
Write that down and then see
which ones are are still living.
And then you have to figure out,
well,
what do you want from your parents?
Exactly.
Do you,
do you want them to apologize?
Do you want them to understand
what they did wrong?
Do you want to punish them?
Do you want to get,
let them get you,
let them learn to know you better?
Do you want to change the way
they're interacting with you now?
Do you want to learn your own lessons
from your bad experience so that when
you're a parent,
you don't make the same mistake?
You merely want to have a chance to
express yourself like it's very difficult
to,
to answer your question because
I don't know what your goal is,
right?
So we bet and,
and I don't need to know.
You need to know what are the resentments
so we can walk through the process we
already described.
Lay them out and comprehensively you
might want to make a list of everything
that you think you might conceivably
be annoyed about with regards to your
parents no matter how trivial,
right?
Cause then that way you,
you scour your memory for four,
four,
four things that you're
holding onto in a bitter way.
And maybe you have your justification.
I'm not suggesting that you don't,
but you need to discover
what baggage you're carrying.
Then you have to figure out,
well what can I let go of and what's core?
And I would say what's really core is
if there are ways that your
parents treated you that
are still affecting you or
that are affecting your relationships
with them now those really need to be
dealt with because they're not done.
They're not in the past,
right?
They're not even resentments of your job,
but they're still part
of your ongoing life.
And so,
okay,
so now you have all your
resentments laid out.
I guess I would say,
you know,
something like,
look mom and dad,
there's something I need to talk to you
about that's been bothering me for a
long time and I pick one of the
trivial things to begin with.
It's like,
here's a memory I have and don't get
all high and mighty about it because you
know,
you might have misconstrued
the situation as a child,
it's highly probable.
And they may have had their reasons and
you may not even remember the situation,
let's say correctly or the
way they remembered to say,
well,
here's,
here's something that happened
when I was a kid in it.
It still bothers me in,
do you remember what happened?
That's an open ended question.
Do you remember what happened?
Why did this,
why did this go this way?
And then I would do an
awful lot of listening,
you know,
because you are trying to
gather information and the
more your parents can tell
you about what happened
in those situations,
I would say the better
off you're likely to be.
So that's about all I can say about that.
That's fairly delineated
approach to general discussions
about difficult things.
Right?
But I would say don't be afraid of,
don't be more afraid of engaging in
this process then you are afraid of not
engaging in it.
Like every relationship you have
is going to have problems in it.
And you know,
you don't want to jump to a intense
psychological discussion with every little
bump.
But if there's something,
um,
medium to longterm permanence
that's disturbing you,
or a pattern that repeats
itself at least three times,
let's say,
well then that might be something that's
worthy of discussion or your discovery
that you're very dissatisfied with
the way the relationship is going,
and you have to have the conflict
necessary to sort that out.
And it's going to be conflict with you
and the Co and the person that you're
talking to.
But the aim should be the establishment
of something like fully informed,
fully negotiated medium to longterm piece.
That's what you're aiming at.
If you have any sense.